alright Oprah Winfrey is revealing her
new and highly anticipated book club
selection only on CBS this morning good
morning CTM family and everybody hello
I'm safer at home and I hope you all are
too but really pleased to be able to
tell you about my next book club
selection no better time to get a good
book and this is a really good one it is
a true story and it's called Hidden
Valley Road inside the mind of an
American family by Robert Kolker Hidden
Valley Road and what an incredible story
it is true story about this family of 12
and it's discovered one by one by one by
one by one by one that six members of
this family of the boys all have
schizophrenia and it's like a detective
story that reveals the shame the denial
the shock the confusion the
misunderstanding of dealing with mental
illness at a time when nobody was really
sure what schizophrenia was or how to
treat it
Robert Kolker does an incredible job of
exploring the minds of this family
Robert Kolker is a New York Times
bestselling author he joins us from his
home in Brooklyn New York good morning
congratulations first of all what was it
like to hear Oprah giving the big pitch
for your book well it's the third time
I've watched the video and I'm still
hyperventilating I can't get enough of
it I'm just amazed and and overwhelmed
and thrilled and and more to the point
I'm just thrilled for this family who
opened up to tell their story after
decades of silence and hopefully the the
this selection by Oprah really is
helpful to them in this way too this is
a family the the Galvin family that had
six sons diagnosed with schizophrenia
family of 12 kids in an age
when people didn't want to talk about
mental illness at all and certainly
didn't understand it why did they want
to tell this story to you well there
were really two big questions when I
first heard about this family one was
how on earth could this happened to one
family and that was the science question
that I think the family still wants
answers to and and the book is helpful
that way I hope and then the second
question is how on earth could this
family actually remain a family given
all of the tragedy they experienced and
I think they wanted that investigated
also I mean they wanted their tale to be
instructive to people and helpful to
people I found that by telling this
story as a nonfiction narrative as a
family saga you really get the sense of
these people as people first and their
ordeals are really relatable what they
went through is really quite extreme and
quite tragic but I think there's hope in
there and and helpfulness and art the
story that it can tell people yeah and
you really come to know all of them in
this book Gale you've got a question - I
do
Bob Coulter hi you might get a kick out
of this I was talking to Oprah last
night about hi about the book selection
and she said that a member of her team
gave her the book because she and Prince
Harry are working on a series about
mental health and so she was reading it
as for in preparation for her mental
health work but she said I was so
fascinated because it was written like a
novel she very seldom - she very very
seldom chooses non-fiction books so to
her surprise because it is so well done
and it does read like a novel you can't
believe what you're reading that's why
she chose it and I'm one of the the
thing that resonated with me about the
book is that the woman thought that she
was - the mom mean II thought she was
doing everything perfectly if she was
making for instance a different kind of
pie every night she thought that she was
keeping the family together with the
simplicity of that when everything is
just really going to hell in a
handbasket there was a lot of shame and
a lot of stigma about mental illness
back in the 50s and 60s when the galvan
boys were first getting sick and there's
still a stigma now of course - but it
really was extreme back then and it all
pointed toward
parents back then the the major
psychiatrists in our society all were
blaming mom and dad for schizophrenia
and so families like the Galvan's knew
that if they went public with what was
going on that they would be judged and
the family would be destroyed so she had
a lot riding on that yeah you can you
can only imagine Baba Tony to cope well
here before we let you go I wanted to
sneak in a quick question about the
impact that this family and and they're
telling their story has on the wider
scientific understanding of
schizophrenia and how we treat it um
they really have pushed the ball forward
in ways that even surprised them they
were one of the first families to be
studied by the National Institute of
Mental Health back in the 80s when
technology was just starting to give us
a little glimpse into the genome and
they are still the biggest family in the
collection of families with genes like
this and toward the end of Hidden Valley
Road you can learn all about the
different genetic mutations that this
family pointed the way toward that might
help us understand this disease better
and actually might help future
generations it really is an epic story
Robert Colker thank you so much Hidden
Valley Road is on sale now